hello everyone and welcome to a most
exciting game from round two of the
Zagreb Grantchester being played in
Croatia
it's Magnus cross and vs. which monitor
the two old rivals are brawling it out
again before we check out the game I do
have a very short announcement
my father was supposed to go to a ZZ Top
concert in Austria in two days on the
29th of June but he decided not to go
and if any of you are interested maybe
if you're from Austria if you are or if
you're interested in going to Austria if
you want to check out the concert just
contact me via any you know either via
Gmail or Facebook Twitter Instagram
doesn't really matter so if any of you
are interested whoever contacts me first
will will be given the ticket to the
concert so that being said let's check
out the game cross on wood white pieces
opens with d4 we have Knight to f6 by
Anand c4 we have e six and of course you
all know where this is going Knight to
f3 and d5 we have the Queens gambit
declined on the board and they will be
following the game the two of them
already played in the OtterBox Nova
championship this year but also course
and played a very similar line against
LaVon Oregon the gray in the grande
chess classic so let's see what happens
Knight to c3 by crossing with D captures
on c4 and now II for preparing to
recapture on c4 and Bishop to b4 now
with Bishop to g5 by Carlsen c5 now and
now captures on c4 will see captures on
d4 Knight captures on d4 and now of
course the capture on c3 it is the main
line with B captures and Queen to a5 and
here Crossin already had this position
against onion in the green key chess
class again against fish in the auto box
no weight championship here he played
Bishop to d2 against onion and he won a
game against Oregon in grain key but he
played nice to be five against Anand in
Norway chess and that game ended in a
draw but here a cross and decides to go
for the main line which is Bishop to b5
this comes with check and well obviously
he prepared something new in the main
line with Bishop to d7
Bishop captures on f6 first and now you
can either capture aji Capra's on f6 or
you can go for this capture on c3 first
captures
on c3 is a bad move it has been played
although it pretty much loses the game
because after King f1 yes you captured
the bishop would check but after Knight
captures here you open up an attack
against the black queen also threatening
Knight to c7 check and here black would
adjust a black will just lose a lot of
material if Queen captures you deliver
this check King e7i captures here and if
you will have no problems escaping with
the night so after Bishop captures will
G captures on f6 and now Bishop captures
and d7 going for more trades night
chapter 77 and here you don't gain
anything by trying to protect the c3
pawn crossing just castles Anand grabs
the pawn with Queen captures on c3 and
now comes Queen a4 now saying to black
if you Castle I'm going to capture your
knight so what do you want to do here
and interestingly of course and castles
it's not a problem because now if you
capture then you get to this rooked a to
d8 a move it has been played before I
think more rows which had one game with
the black pieces in this line and then
of course after you move the King the
Queen you will get Queen captures on d4
black recaptures the piece and black
will well black's pawn structure is a
bit meh stopped on the Kings side it's
not really an issue black and just move
the King place the rooks on the G file
and use them for attack let's say so
instead after castles Carlsen goes
Knight captures on e6 first now if you
capture here and only then will I
capture your night while well I've
already recapture the pawn so nice the
b6 with an attack on the Queen with
Queen to d4 offering a trade of Queens
and now rook F to c8 in defending the
Queen
so still F captures in e6 is a threat
here cross and decides the trade we have
Queen captures rook captures and now
comes Knight to f4 you can no longer
leave your knight on e6 and now rook the
c5 preparing f5 to get rid of his
doubled pawn and well capture on e4 or
maybe Magnus will capture on f5 rook F
to D one now by Carson and now f5 s plan
with each captures on f5 and here not
recapturing immediately but first rook a
to c8 he wants the
grab hold of the C file and gain full
development across and says okay you're
gonna have to work for this pawn so he
pushes f6 and now Anand has to go for it
will look to a5 and now g3 defending the
knight but you do have to part with your
f6 pawn with rook captures on f6 and now
rook to d3 with rook F to c6 back to the
C C file and now rook to a3 asking what
do you want to do with the a 7-point and
here Anand first decides to get rid of
one pair of rooks we have rooks e1 check
rook captures rook captures with check
with King to g2 and now Knight to c8 the
guarding the a7 pawn he doesn't want to
push any pawns create some new
weaknesses so just bringing the right
back you cannot attack it the rookie is
the defending it from the C file but now
rook the d3 going for rook to d7 you
want to start attacking this pawns from
the seventh rank so of course
Anand prevents this wave rook to c7 and
now rook to d8 check with King to g7 and
now h4 s Carson does have a three-to-two
advantage on the Kings side so first
you're gonna want to try and play there
as it's unlikely that you will be able
to pick up any of the Queen side points
where Anand has a two-to-one advantage
with Knight to e7 by Anand and now
tonight the h5 check g4 was also one of
the suggestions but Knight to h5 is
played here and here it's strongest to
go King to g6 but here aren't plays King
to h6 and he allows a Magnus some very
nice tactics cross and goes Knight to f6
preparing to go Knights the e8 followed
by rook to d6 check we have King to g6
now pushing the knight back night Stewie
8 and now you have to decide either
you're gonna allow rook d6 check or
you're gonna defend the 6th rank with
rook and allow rook to d7 allowing this
check is very dangerous for example if
you play some let's say this try try and
force a trade then look these six will
be very dangerous because the knight
controls this square root controls these
squares g5 is taken if you go to h5 then
something like King h3 followed by g4
will be deadly so you would have to go
king f5 and then after Knight to g7
check you're going to have
go down the board and now again white
will get rook d7 at some point attacking
the knight attacking us or attacking the
knight attacking the pawn and b7 and the
black King although active is a bit too
active for it for his own good
so after 98 Aaron decides to keep an eye
on the 6th rank so look to c6 and now
comes look to d7 cross and gets his a
double attack here and now well you
could play something like Knight to c8
to try and give up the b7 pawn Anand
finds a different idea first rook to
East 6 keeping an eye on on the knight
here as the knight was under attack but
here cross and pushes h5 and now of
course you don't want to capture it if
you capture it you get an IG 7 check you
lose the rook and the game of course
so after h5 we have King back to h6 and
now Knight to d6 by Carlson going after
the pawn but with the night he still
wants to keep his rook here we have
although if you capture with the rook
for example rook captures here it's
gonna be very hard to get the rock out
of there
Black's gonna go Knight to c8 open up an
attack against across since night here
and after remove the knight Knight c7
only square available to the knight
black is gonna go rookie 7 and you're
never moving or pieces from from D
squares again
so after King h6 we have Knight to d6
now going after the pawn with the night
and now comes f5 by Anand he says ok
maybe you want to capture my capture my
knight and then I can capture your
knight
but the idea is if you captured the
night you cannot capture the rook
because Knight f5 check again picks up
the rook and you would just be up a
piece so here with Knight captures on b7
by cross and it is the strongest move
and now Knight the g8 by armand with
Knight back to d6 attacking the a7 pawn
but now Knight to f6 going after the
rook here also if you tried something
like Knight something like King to g5 to
defend your f5 pawn then ideas like f4
become possible and that protein
captures on h5 you will again have
Knight captures on f5 King g6 now g4 is
coming and it will be very
unpleasant to play this for black
so after this Knight to d6 move we have
Knight to f6 by Hannon and now Knight
captures on f5 with check King to g5 and
not night the d4 attacking on ins rook
and here you have to decide do you want
to trade and go into this night and pawn
and game or do you want to go rook to a6
rook to a6 is very interesting because
after looped to a6 you allow ideas like
f4 check and then after King captures on
h5 you were gonna go rook the g7 cut the
King off from entering the game and then
your plan is king to h3 you're gonna
push g4 here you're gonna go night 5 and
it will be very hard for black to defend
even if you capture this with check King
h3 now you have to prevent her rook g5
check Ruby g5 check will be followed by
Knight to a5 checkmate so you have to
prevent it
rokay 5 but then you get nice the east 6
and after any move by black you're gonna
go Knight to f8 rogue d5 you're gonna go
rook to f7 attack the knight and after
loop to b6 defending the knight you're
gonna go g4 check King to h6 and only
now or if you capture it if you go to h6
you're getting getting made it just a
king to h4 and there's no preventing a
g5 whatever you do g5 is coming and it's
game over so here after g4 check you
you'll probably have I mean you will
have to capture it and then you get rook
a5 check King to h6 and just king
capture some G for your upper piece even
though you can try and harass this night
and tonight currently has no escape
route you will simply bring your King
over to e5 and then the knight will be
able to jump back to this square so not
a problem
for example whatever you play a fiber
just gonna King e4 look to a6 whatever
can be 5 and out the Knights can come
back into the game and you'll have
plenty of time to stop the deep past a
pawn so very interesting idea rook to a
6 but even this is what the best defense
for black and it's hard to play the best
defense when when your King has so few
squares to go to Anand decides against
this he decides to go into the night and
pawn endgame
with Knight captures sorry first night
capture 77 Knight captures on e6 and now
King captures on h5 and here came to f3
by Carlsen so Carson is up upon but
still it's not all that clear how you're
gonna move forward from this point we
have King to g6 by Anand now King to f4
King to f6 and now Knight to g5 going
after the h7 pawn we have h6
and now Knight to e4 with check pushing
down pushing the King back kink the e6
and here Carson played King to g4 and
this is not the the most appropriate way
to deal with this endgame it's there of
course the the line I'm gonna show is
from Sesay so of course it's not to be
expected for for anyone to play it but
f3 is the way to go and after black
makes a move let's say 95 you want to go
g4 and now use the g3 squared to bring
your knight over to f5 to harass your to
harass th a 6 point from here and then
you will force black to move all the way
back with the King before continuing to
improve your the position of your own
King so this is the most precise way to
go about it but ok with King to g4 by
Carson King to e5 and now we have f3
defending the knight but here Allen
finds the most precise way to defend
King to d4 and now if the White King
attacks the H pawn now you go
King here and you attack the weak f3
pawn so what do you do here well you
could go Knight to d6 this is one way to
go about it and then after 95 check you
can go king f4 night the d3 check King
get 5 and then after night to see 1 you
will go Knight to the b5 check King d5
you can trade everything Knight captures
Knight captures and then you will have
this position where both nights are
around the rim but you have a two-to-one
advantage on the King side and although
it should be winning it's still you know
there's a lot of play to it but here
again Carson went king to f5 and he'll
out King to III by Anand with f4 now of
course you don't want a lot black to
capture and now aged 5 and here Carlsen
really wanting to a deep think as you
probably figure out that he messed it up
somewhere he doesn't know where as it
I mean a disgusting engine line but you
know still he took a lot of time here I
think some 30 minutes to figure out
where to go from here and if you try
something like a four it's gonna explain
that we're gonna show then you get kink
to f3 kink the e6 attacks the knight
Knight of faith check and then after
King t5 you're just gonna repeat 96
check King to f5 we're gonna repeat 97
check King g5 knight c6 check and you're
not gonna be making any progress so here
a cross and after some 30 minutes of
thought played Knight to g5 which is
very nice because here Anand has a very
clean draw but he didn't go for it and
King to have to is a beautiful draw
because King to f2 is a forcing line
that goes g4 h capture screen captures
and now came to e3 and now basically
what you want to do is give up your
night for this pawn and charge your king
over to the Queen to the Queen side a
win this pawn and then white will be
unable to win with even being up a
knight basically King a five-night c5 is
the move to find because now the night
completely controls the king you cannot
move away because you're gonna lose the
DF pawn you cannot go here the knight
guards this square and the point being
if you go Kings to e5 doesn't really do
anything because just night d3 check
wins bf4 pawn and even if you try
something like Knight h3 to the faint
red pawn doesn't really matter just 93
blacks is gonna give up the night like
the King g5 you're gonna give up the
night and run away and well win this
pawn so white will be unable to win with
with the extra night so this was the
nice draw on and could have gone for but
Aaron goes night to c5 a different line
and now again cousin has to decide what
to do here Carlson played King to g6 he
wants to go after this pawn here but
again uh I moved to he should have
played is King to f6 and now after King
f2 after you go after this point you hit
f5 and now after King captures and g3
King to East 7 and now the king will
nicely guard all of the squares that
this night can use to attack this pawn
so here we would probably see h4 f6 but
now Knight the d3 night to the
a sneaky move because if you continue
with f6 you would actually blunder
blunder greatly as night here and you
lose the point or you can promote to a
queen and then Knight to g6 check after
the King moves you will win the Queen
push h4 win white tonight and it's it's
very nicely done so what you would have
to do after night d3 first you have to
play king g6 prevent the knight from
reaching the e5 square and then after
night c5 check you're gonna go king d6
now h3 you wanna try and get this night
away from the defense of d4 square as
black wants to play a 94 check pick up
the f6 pawn but white will just ignore
the word you're gonna have f 7h to f8
Queen and now h1 Queen and you're gonna
have this position still not not an easy
anything but it would be probably the
best course of action for white here
you cannot capture the night because
Quincy one would pick up the g5 9 but
you can play Queen a5 and have a have a
nice game so this is one of the ways
across and who could have played it by
king of six just keeping an eye on the
night but Carson decided to go King g6
he wants to win the h5 pawn and then try
and push the F pawn so King to f2 now
and finally gets the King to DF 2
squared with f5 King captures in g3
Knight the e6 now Carson hoping for this
trade of course Anand is not interested
as the DF pawn would be promoted to the
e pond and it would be much too fast so
nice to d7 Anand just keeping an eye on
the f6 square he says if you ever push
it I'm just gonna sacrifice my knight
and I'm gonna rush my King over to the
Queen side to win this pawn and my King
is much faster than your king so King
captures on h5 by Crossan and now King
to f3
we have kinked the g5 and now King to e4
Anand rushing his King over to the Queen
side we have 9th to c7 and now a five
with Knight to be 5 by cross and King to
d3 now with King to g6 and now with a
four by Carlsen
sorry by on earth with King to f7 trying
to push the night away and now Knight to
e5 check with King to f6 and now
Knight to f3 and it's very interesting
how this knight who will be able to keep
an eye on this point but you will see
King is 7 and now of course Carson wants
the marshes pass pawn forward and here
it's again it's a crossroad and it has
to decide what to do here
I don't played King to c2 which is an
interesting move but again there was a
force draw with Knight to h2 again you
cannot push f6 because Knight g4 attack
is the point f7 again 95 and you're in
the same position that you were earlier
you will lose this point if you Queen it
just 96 check picks up the Queen so what
you will have to do here well you will
not have to do anything here as it
wasn't played but here unemployed King
to c2 instead of this night h2 line he
wants to grab the a to pawn so we have
f6 and now comes Knight to g5 again
keeping an eye on this square here but
now Magnus goes for night to d4 check
very interesting cousin had about 30
seconds on the clock at the disposition
Anand had about 13 I believe so Knight
d4 check King Tubby 2 and now comes
night Stewie 6 again hoping for a trade
as his passport would be will be much
faster with night to h7 and now f7 so
still you cannot Queen the pawn but
crossing has Knight to g5 planned with
King captures on a - and now Knights the
g5 but now on and starts pushing his own
past bone as well with a 3 of course you
don't care about your knight anymore
with Knight captures on h7 King to be
won and here
sorry not be - King to be 1 + f8 Queen
finally Magnus brings a queen into the
game with a 2 by Anand and now Queen to
f5 check now this is a unknown
theoretical draw with the knight being
so far away there's no way to actually
win this but cross and decided to give a
few more checks we have King be 225
check King be one with Quinta efore
check King to be - Quinta e - check now
King to be 1 and here Knight to f6 he
tried to bring his knight into the game
so on and finally gets a queen of his
own back into the game we have Knight to
d5 but now a series of checks from Anand
just to show that he
is you know well prepared to draw this
game with King 36 and now Queen to f8
check King e5 and here this is just
beautiful Magnus finishes the game with
King to e5 which seems like he blunders
the Queen and in fact he will lose the
Queen but only temporarily Queen t8 was
played by Bishop King study for and now
Queen captures sunny - so who wins the
Queen but Magnus has Knight to Knight to
c3 check King to a-1 and now Knight
captures on e2 and we have a draw by
insufficient material so I really
enjoyed this entire game everything
about it
Islands very very strong defensive
skills cross and trying to grind it out
but unable to do it and then after a
tough grind for for some 78 moves across
and decides to play this well this
beautiful line King King g5 and allow
this and allow this beautiful trade of
Queens but yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it really really an
impressive game and it really just shows
you how important it is to study the
endgame because here even Magnus Carlsen
world champion who is known to be
probably the greatest end game player in
the history of chess missed his chances
in this game it just shows you how
important it is to always keep brushing
up on your endgame Ovadia I do hope you
enjoyed it one of the one of the more
fighting draws I've seen in a while so
really really enjoyed it we do have the
standings prepared so let's check him
out it's from the chess 24 website so a
nice cross table Janna Konishi with in
first place both wins with 2 points
probably gonna show his game against
Cora wanna tomorrow morning as it was
really interesting then followed by one
and a half point by Magnus Carlsen and
Wesley so then a series of one pointers
Fabiano Caruana maxime partial gravity
mommy they are 11 are in a cyclic
circuit kurakin and then with only half
a point
dinkler and onigiri which one is an
island and he Carl Nakamura so that
being said I do hope you enjoyed it once
again I would like to thank John Roberts
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check - all my previous
videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon most likely continuing the
coverage of the Grantchester in Croatia
in Zagreb but also checking up in your
suggestions if something really you know
extraordinary happens thank you all I
will see you soon have an excellent rest
your day